[Music]
there was growing concern over new
technology there could be the future of
airport security the to it the TSA
rather has a new pilot program that uses
facial recognition technology instead of
checks of boarding passes and driver's
licenses at Los Angeles International
Airport Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan
National Airport outside Washington DC
with more on that story Chris good
morning good morning now this system
works similar to what these clear
terminals do where it will compare a
picture of you up against in this case a
passport photo stored in a secure
government database but critics are
saying facial recognition may not work
the same for everyone
the TSA is trying a facial recognition
system it hopes will speed up lines
while adding a layer of security at LAX
is International Terminal the agency he
is testing a future where fliers won't
need a boarding pass or an ID check to
go through security the passenger
experience is enhanced because you don't
have to fumble through your belongings
to pull out you know multiple ID
documents you just walk up to the camera
post for a photo and you're you're off
on your way the TSA says the images are
not saved on the camera and are compared
against a gallery of passport photos of
people known to be flying that day to
confirm the travelers identity during
the pilot passengers are not required to
participate the process takes as little
as two seconds a standard document check
takes about 20 I'm fine with it I was
just surprised by the people that have
nothing to hide I think there would be
our all for it
the lax test is part of a larger push by
Customs and Border Protection to meet a
congressional mandate for biometric
verification of people entering and
leaving the country the same technology
is being used prior to boarding some
international flights leaving the US and
for people entering the country at
airports including this system at
Washington's Dulles Airport and this
border crossing with Mexico in Texas but
critics worry facial recognition
technology may misidentify people of
color an ACLU test in correctly matched
twenty eight members of Congress
identifying them as people arrested for
a crime the false matches were
disproportionately people of color go
slow building the protections it's
Senator Ed Markey was
so incorrectly matched in the ACLU test
he and Republican Senator Mike Lee have
repeatedly called for the Department of
Homeland Security to halt the rollout of
biometrics while privacy rules are put
in place until they lay out how they're
going to divide this question of
security versus privacy I think that we
want a go slow sign put on the
deployment of this technology do you
feel like they are going slow it the way
it's being rolled out no they're
actually accelerating the deployment of
this technology without first telling
Americans what the protections are for
innocent Americans I think the
technology is mature it's ready kevin
mchale Enon is the CBP commissioner the
facial recognition is very accurate even
even an older photograph we're seeing
very very high mass race 99% plus if we
have a photograph of that traveler
custom says it's still developing those
privacy rules photos of US citizens are
saved for just 12 hours everybody else
for 14 days TSA says they just want to
see how well the software actually works
Nora all right Chris thank you